alexis me poulat bonsoir on vient donc
d'entendre le chef de l'état un peu plus
de dix minutes sur la situation en
afghanistan votre première réaction
qu'est ce que vous retenez de cette
prise de parole
une allocution extrêmement courtes qui
dit les choses c'est une débâcle la
france organise le rapatriement dans la
la la la cohue de ses ressortissants
alors que les spécialistes alertait déjà
depuis des semaines enfin emmanuel
macron propose l'asile aux
collaborateurs de l'armée française à
ceux qui sont en première ligne
maintenant la bae et à risque de
représailles de la part des talibans
c'est la moindre des choses et puis bien
sûr un point sur la gestion migratoire
qui risque de déstabiliser une fois
encore les régions européennes avec une
réponse qui va être disparate puisque on
a très peu entendu l'union européenne
qui a simplement dit attention les
talibans soyez gentils s'il vous plaît
donc on voit bien que la est acté la
défaite de la stratégie américaine et de
l'otan dans ce pays qui décidément
surprend puisque joe biden disette en
juillet que la prise de kaboul étaient
sans doute peu possible voire impossible
de la part des talibans en quelques
semaines elle a été fait en quelques
jours on a l'impression qu'il y ait un
mensonge total une méconnaissance totale
aussi de la part des occidentaux de ce
pays qui maintenant est bien va se
retrouver aux prises avec les talibans
qui compte bien je pense avoir une
revanche par rapport à ce qui a été une
occupation et une guerre de 20 ans
alexis une prise de parole du président
c'est plutôt rare les dernières on s'en
souvient elle concernait les
restrictions sanitaires est-ce que
c'était important selon vous que le
président français ils interviennent
rapidement devant les citoyens pour
parler cette situation afghanistan
c'est noël macron a pris pour habitude
de prendre la parole tout le temps pour
ne rien dire on l'a vu revenir un an
après au chevet du livre dont il avait
promis monts et merveilles le liban est
dans une faillite totale également avec
là encore une fois aucune aide concrète
ou réelle ou urgentes de la part de
l'union europé enne maintenant de
l'afghanistan pour acter la défaite est
rassuré j'imagine les nombreux prend
c'est inquiet qui sont encore présents
sur le territoire afghan qui attendent
de savoir comment ils vont être
rapatriés dans quelles conditions et
puis bien sûr ces mesures ou les
conseils de défense ont été dévoyés 1
puisqu'il était utilisé pour traiter une
crise sanitaire aujourd'hui un conseil
de défense qui était dans sa forme
normale c'est-à-dire pour parler de
questions de géopolitique de
géostratégie et de défense en
l'occurrence quelle va être la réponse
des forces françaises à la question
afghane
dans le cadre bien sûr d'une réponse
internationale coordonnée puisqu'il a
rappelé qu' aujourd'hui européens russes
et toute la communauté internationale
doit travailler ensemble puisque les
intérêts sont communs c'est une première
enfin disons que ça commence à se voir
donc l'otan est a été une faillite les
états unis encore une fois comme au
vietnam ont passé 20 ans d'occupation de
déstabilisation ou les compagnies
privées de sécurité comme halliburton ou
blackwater ont pu faire des milliards de
dollars de profits grâce à la misère
provoquée par ces guerres sans fin il a
redit aussi en l'a compris entre ligne
que la france elle devait encore
rayonner la france pays des droits de
l'homme et des lumières devaient être
encore rayonner à l'avenir en
afghanistan quels moyens selon vous
est-ce qu'on a les moyens encore
aujourd'hui d'avoir une influence là bas
pour faire vivre la démocratie
alors s'il influences françaises en
afghanistan et envoyé bhl ou quelques
forces spéciales non ça va pas vraiment
être une influence importante
malheureusement je ne vois pas quel
pourquoi peut avoir la france que quand
on sait le prix d'une opération
extérieure le coût d'une opération
extérieure la difficulté bien sûr de
l'organiser dans le chaos total qu'elle
a prise de pouvoir des talibans
actuellement partout dans le pays on
voit bien que même au mali là où la
france était à la manoeuvre la
difficulté totale avec les soubresauts
des rêves des derniers mois
c'est extrêmement compliqué je crois que
c'est illusoire de croire que la france
va être un game 'changer comme on dit qu
un pays qui va pouvoir changer la donne
dans cette région tourmentée seule une
réponse internationale et puis bien sûr
une concertation maintenant de l'ordre
de la diplomatie puisqu'il est acté que
les talibans ont gagné va permettre
d'éviter le pire aux afghans et en
afghanistan alors les américains et
leurs alliés dont la france un bouc
n'ont apparemment pas vu un tel scénario
venir on est tous surpris depuis 48
heures comment est ce que vous comprenez
bien c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure le l'impression que soient les
américains ont menti à tout le monde
puisqu'il était question d'une armée
afghane formé de plus de 500 mille
membres avec 80 milles forces spéciales
avec du matériel dernier cri et donc il
partait confiant que cette armée afghane
assure après eux l'ordre dans le pays il
n'en est rien donc soit ils ont été
totalement berner par les talibans qui
se sont fait passer pour des forces de
l'armée régulière soit ils ont dans
petit saut tout simplement créer un rêve
celui d'un pays contrôlé par l'étranger
avec des forces d'occupation qui allait
partir cette annonce par
l'administration trump s'est fait par
joe biden la surprise est totale donc on
peut se poser la question sur les
services de renseignement à la fois de
l'otan des américains et de leurs alliés
elles sont ils à la hauteur il ya une
vraie question qui se pose parce que
c'est des milliers de vies maintenant
d'afghans qui sont en jeu deux
ressortissants étrangers également qui
se pose la question de comment partir on
voit ces scènes terribles à l'aéroport
de kaboul où les avions militaires sont
pris d'assaut par des piétons qui
essaient de monter dans les avions qui
décollent et qui tombe du ciel on
imagine que ce chaos là il aurait pu
être prévisible si les services de
renseignement avaient fait leur travail
sur place donc on a l'impression d'un
énorme gâchis du d'une énorme du prix
également de la part de l'administration
maiden qui assurait la semaine dernière
que tout allait très bien se passer avec
le départ des troupes américaines merci
beaucoup alexis poulain d'avoir
décrypter avec nous ce soir la prise de
parole des manuels macro moins sur la
situation en afghanistan